we don't realize that we incrementally
gave up on the idea that our lives could
be filled with an exciting parade of
major
Innovations
icai and I find it terrifying I find it
terrifying the effect it's going to have
on on people's jobs the fact that it's
going to obliterate a lot of jobs what
effect is that going to have on society
am I am I right you just lost your
capitalist model
you have a fabric that is overlying the
entire world that directs people whether
to get up in the morning and what to do
once they once they do rise
and it tells them how to do things
without having addicted
so this it's not just the Invisible Hand
it's the invisible mesh
and this invisible mesh if it breaks
means people are not going to know what
to do in the morning
all hell's about to break loose and my
question is are you trying to figure out
which way the wave is going to break and
get your surfboard in the water we
should be sitting around talking about
what is the new economics instead what
we're talking about is
how do we keep communism at Bay while
capitalism is struggling
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is a
physicist he's one of the smartest
people in the world and a friend of the
show Eric Weinstein welcome to
trigonometry hey it's great to be here
thanks guys uh it's really good to have
you on the show Eric it's been a long
time coming so exciting to have you here
but listen you know for a lot of people
who watch our show you will be one of
the IDW guys who was part of this sort
of weird emerging thing a few years ago
and they won't actually know who you are
exactly they'll know you for the things
you say what what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here because you've done a lot
of interesting things right so I
sometimes I try to avoid being known to
the audience I would say that I by
profession I started off trying to do
physics but realizing that physics was
in a terrible situation so I ended up
doing the mathematics that allowed me to
Shadow the physics that I wanted to be
doing
um in a certain sense uh a lot of who I
am is a person who has believed deeply
that the master narratives that govern
our time have been getting weirder and
wackier so I started I would say late
80s early 90s really exploring the idea
that our institutions are much farther
gone and much stranger and weirder than
anyone expects and because that has such
a high social cost or at least had such
a high social cost when you explored it
at that time it was kind of an open
world and I would say the people who had
been particularly active in Progressive
politics were about the only people who
believed
that a lot of these structures were
really far decayed that the narratives
were wildly off of what was actually
happening and I've tried tracking that I
would say through economics labor
markets financial instruments political
skullduggery
science
the ways in which the military complex
interacts with all of these things from
art to physics to news and
beyond that I mean my my personal life
is something that I really probably care
about even more than any of this and all
of these actions
are really because I have children on
this planet and I'm deeply concerned
that they have a happy optimistic and
positive future and I have to I feel
personally responsible for clearing away
a lot of stuff that we're not supposed
to talk about because
as we are increasingly seen we grew up
thinking we were in a free Society but
that is actually governed by these
incredibly strong narratives that are
clearly untrue and they're very
difficult to source as to why is it that
so many people pretend to believe things
that no one can believe in in
in an individual instance I hear you and
particularly on the feeling of
responsibility now that I've become a
father as well like that I get it I get
it but before we get into the narratives
and the institutions and all of that
what was wrong with physics what's wrong
with physics what was wrong with physics
wrong with physics now I mean the fact
is this is the 50th anniversary
of a couple of developments one of which
was February 1st 1973 called the
Kobayashi mascara augmentation of the
kabibo angle which introduced three
families of matter into the standard
model but that picture of the matter in
this room who and what we actually are
as waves propagating through the
space-time that Einstein gave us that
model has been stagnant for 50 years and
as I was just saying on Joe Rogan if you
think about songs from that period of
time like Crocodile Rock or Thai yellow
ribbon around the old oak tree imagine
that playing on a continuous loop for 50
years without any real progress and the
underlying understanding of the world
that's a catastrophe because it means
that you replace all of the people who
knew what science was with a group of
people who will tell you well in science
this is the way things go yet they have
no understanding of science having never
contributed so why is it go to that
stage why has this happened Derek it's
an interesting question why does it
happen furthermore across multiple
Fields why is it that for example
evolutionary theory in terms of the
sexual
and natural selection theories why did
that stagnate when it tried to go into
sociobiology and ran into political
problems why is it that neoclassical
economics hardened into Dogma
uh in all of these situations we have
the fact that there was something that
was going on late 60s early 70s
that ossified and except in the fields
of computation Communications
things largely stagnated and it's hard
to think about because so much so much
of our lives are digital that the fact
thank God that we had Moore's Law and
these explosions in computation we
almost don't notice that that feeling
that the world is taking place at breath
neck Pace Breakneck Pace at a
breathtaking speed rather it's hard to
confuse those two that feeling derives
almost entirely from our digital lives
and the Innovations in software and
computation and artificial intelligence
all of those things but oddly that neon
sign that poster the fact that we're
filming in a studio all of those things
were possible in 1973 it might have been
more expensive but the only really novel
thing here is is that you're able to
push this out without a Broadcast News
station wow so I mean that says a lot
about not only science but it says a lot
about Society because if Society is not
innovating it's effectively dying isn't
it well again it's not that we're not
innovating at all but if you think about
you know the jet packs for example that
were featured in a James Bond film in
the 1970s
we always wondered when were we going to
get personal jet packs we're still
dealing with the idea that they're quite
hard to stabilize
um if you go to the airport in Los
Angeles where I'm from there's a
completely space-age futuristic building
that dominates the architecture it's
still the most futuristic thing in the
city I mean we somehow
took on a very different perspective at
the future I just was dealing with
somebody involved in the relaunch of the
DeLorean Motor Company and 40 years
later the DeLorean is still absolutely
something that excites us because it is
new
and I just find this fascinating that we
don't realize that we incrementally gave
up on the idea that our lives could be
filled with an exciting parade of major
Innovations and I was just on stage in
Miami at Bitcoin talking about the three
white papers that changed the world and
one of them was Bitcoin the the the
blockchain white paper and from 2008
one of them was something called that
tension is all you need from 2017 which
changed the large language model
landscape and one of them was the 2018
proposal from the Eco Health Alliance
that we should start experimenting with
fear and cleavage sites and Spike
protein and coronavirus wow
he left that one for the for the end
there Eric you know one of the
interesting things that you mentioned
there is something that I think is part
of this whole thing that confronts all
of us who are trying to think about
these things which is our vision of our
future and of ourselves is fundamentally
changed and I remember as a boy growing
up reading science fiction about the
great the great challenges that Humanity
would face as it expanded into the
universe and how when you create a
spin-off of your civilization different
planet or as you introduce robotics as
introduce this new challenges come along
and it was almost taken for granted in
that era having just watched you know
first of all my guys alone a man into
space and your guys put one on the moon
and all of that that this would continue
that these vast breakthroughs in human
achievement would continue and now we
sort of squabble about tax rates and and
stuff like that maddening isn't it yeah
because there was nowhere to go you see
what did we really do did we put a man
on the moon or did we put a man on an
ICBM and said it was moon mission
at some level that was also a giant head
fake right because we knew that there
was almost nowhere to go I mean
basically there's the moon and there's
Mars and then you're out of range of
anything interesting with chemical
rockets and I can even ask
you know if you've ever been to Joshua
Tree in Southern California you have an
idea what it might be like to be on Mars
it's beautiful but it gets old pretty
quickly
um I think in part that that's not the
issue the issue is what happens when you
take a moonless night
and you go out when there isn't a cloud
in the sky and you lay on your back
maybe during a meteor shower and you
gaze up at the heavens and you think why
is it that Uruguay is on my bucket list
when I can see the heavens you know I
mean I'm seeing galaxies I'm seeing uh
unbelievable objects and I know that
some of those are stars and some of them
are galaxies
that's where we're supposed to be
dreaming and the only way to get out of
here and to go find that and find out
what the universe is is physics so while
many things stagnated the unforgivable
thing that's diagnated the singular
unforgivable thing is our understanding
of the most basic notion of who we are
when we lost the taste and we're in the
process of not only stagnating physics
but killing the impetus to solve these
problems
there's a new kind of ethos that says
that to ask for an ultimate theory is
immodest
it's destructive it is fundamentally
imperious
that really begins to scare me that we
start thinking about these things in
terms of very personal negative
characteristics of arrogance
of hubris and you understand where it
comes from right because we did unlock
this power
and in particular in 1952 and forget
about the the actual atomic bombs
dropped on on humans tragic as they may
be but potential tragedy
of hydrogen weapons uh
we with that we came to understand we're
really good at this
we're really incredible and we have to
watch ourselves and I think that that's
the right ethos is that we need to worry
about ourselves
but to stop ourselves
we've now crawled into the valley of
death and the trick is to get out to the
other side and to get to the cosmos and
to start to feel
that we're being invited to the World's
Greatest Adventure what people might say
and I I mean I I have some sympathy with
this argument you made it yourself only
a few minutes ago which is the pace of
change is such that we are rapidly
developing technologies that are
breaking the world around us uh if you
look at the impact social media has had
on the way that human beings communicate
uh I mean nuclear weapons is another
example of course but you you could you
could give others where the
technological progress we make is so
disruptive yeah to our world that I
don't blame people who think why don't
we just slow down a bit and tell me
something when your wife's water broke
what was your what was your sense of
like oh shoot we got to stabilize the
situation uh how do we make sure that
our child can stay in here forever no
it's an invitation our water just broke
yeah what could happen next could be
absolutely deadly
but to not understand that it is now
time to call the hospital to get that
bag together to run like hell to care
about those less fortunate than
ourselves because they may be
incapacitated
I don't think we're understanding what
this moment is for example the idea that
I believe it's four amino acids and 12
nucleotides that shut down planet Earth
whether or not that came from a Pangolin
or a laboratory does not matter it's a
tiny change that led to a virality
this is the leverage level that we're
now talking about where a tiny change in
the world with a large enough lover
Archimedes was simply right
this is the opportunity and you know in
the Jewish tradition I have at least
something I can say which is don't wait
for the bread to rise this is your
moment you're being invited out
But Eric look and I'm not a scientist
and my background isn't in science but I
see AI
and the rise of AI and to me and I'm of
a slightly you know pessimistic mindset
okay
but icai and I find it terrifying I find
it terrifying the effect it's going to
have on on people's jobs the fact that
it's going to obliterate a lot of jobs
what effect is that going to have on
society am I am I right you just lost
your capitalist model
you have a model with two inputs called
K and L that's taught in every
University that subscribes to
neoclassical economics what's AI is it l
is it labor is it capital what the heck
is it this is the first time that humans
are not being chased into higher and
higher levels of work we're being chased
out of repetitive work whether it's high
level repetitive work the way that a
neurosurgeon might perform
or low-level repetitive work
so your model
of Economics just broke
now when your water breaks when your
wife's water breaks it doesn't mean that
the baby is born instantly when the
contractions are coming you know 15
minutes apart it's not yet time to be
born this is the moment why are we not
holding a conference on after capitalism
and communism what is the next economic
system do you imagine that Adam Smith
and Karl Marx would just be sitting on
their hands no they'd be smart enough to
say okay we now need a new model it is
bizarre that we are sitting here in
nerves saying
gosh
this is going to break capitalism well
no kidding this is going to break
Capital it's entirely clear that it's
going to break capitalism
and
you have this fabric it's really
fascinating you have a fabric that is
overlying the entire world that directs
people whether to get up in the morning
and what to do once they once they do
rise
and it tells them how to do things
without having a dictator
so this it's not just the Invisible Hand
it's the invisible mesh
and this invisible mesh if it breaks
means people are not going to know what
to do in the morning
and now you can see that this is going
to break it now you have a brief period
of time with what my wife uh
has called it she's an economist with
the institute for New Economic thinking
she says this is the Golden Age of AI
complementarity where a human being
making prompts can ask the large
language model or neural net whatever
whatever you like
questions and the two of them in
dialogue can create something it's sort
of like when humans and computers
started playing chess together
this is going to quickly give way to
where the AI says I can take it from
here
how quickly do you think it's going to
be Eric
probably pretty quick
but keep in mind that
there's some things that could happen
because what these machines are doing is
reading a human Corpus
uh when it comes to language models
let's say it could be that they
asymptote based on how clever we've been
for example they don't do a very good
job in areas where there are fewer than
200 people writing about a very high
level scientific subject so I asked
these computer models a lot about
determinant line bundles not something
in general
conversation and they're terrible at it
because they don't know what to read or
how much they don't have enough so it's
possible that I that that could
asymptote
but the thing you really have to keep in
mind is that a clever person at one of
these AI outfits might figure out how to
teach can computers
to do things that no one has done
so we know that they have emergent
behaviors that you may not teach them
Bengali but they realize they have to
learn Bengali in order to tell you about
tagore so learn Bengali they do that's
an emergent Behavior
what happens when they start to uh
well you know I hesitate to give you an
example because I think this could be
weaponized so maybe I'm not going to say
what I think you could actually teach
one of these machines to do
all hell's about to break loose and my
question is are are you trying to figure
out which way the wave is going to break
and get your surfboard in the water are
you are you trying to figure out how to
anticipate this no in general we sit
around worrying about it in the most
inert way possible and I just don't
understand the Learned helplessness this
is your wife's water is broken and
you're thinking this is terrible he's
like you have to be thinking get to the
hospital agreed temperamentally I'm with
you but I think what Francis is getting
at is look I introduced you as one of
the smartest people in the world I stand
by that introduction there are also some
other smart people who are some of whom
are saying we've got to shut the [__]
down right now we need a moratorium we
can't allow this how's that working
I I don't agree that I don't know I'm
not saying whether it's a good idea
about it yeah what I'm saying is how is
it working when China exactly in Russia
and Iran are reading these papers that's
why it's not going to work and I I agree
with you but Michael I think our
question that we're trying to get at is
why is are people like Elon Musk so
concerned about AI because he's smart
because he doesn't see anybody really
I mean look
I don't know Elon and I are sort of
leading parallel logs he must be aware
of me sometimes answers me on on Twitter
and sometimes we encounter each other in
spaces but we know probably 25 people in
common at a very high level we never
encounter each other I can't tell you
what's going on with you Elon is on all
of the major narratives and I 90 to 95
agree with him on everything right up
until the very end and I don't know why
that goes wrong but his whole narrative
about getting off the planet and
diversifying the number of places where
the spark of human consciousness can be
found without having all of our eggs in
one basket 100 right and then it becomes
a SpaceX pitch for Mars which loses me
but then again I don't own a chemical
Rocky company
in the case of AI you know the fact is
he was seeing this early and he saw Sam
Altman make these other decisions they
were all at this Porter you know I think
Sam wasn't at the Puerto Rico conference
but all of these folks who are at the
Puerto Rico conference knew that this
was coming now 2017 is the dividing line
I think in AI because this paper
attention is all you need makes it clear
to all of us not through the paper but
through the consequences
this is as real as a heart attack so
what are the consequences
say more so for instance you said the
consequences are as real as a heart
attack because you now have chat GPT you
don't need to read a paper about what
academically can happen you can sit in
your room and come up with the most
Twisted question you like
and watch what unfolds you can watch it
fail to do things like it doesn't seem
to know how to do palindromes very well
palindromes are very hard if I give it a
piece of typeset mathematics and ask it
to generate the code that would give
that it doesn't seem to know how to do
that yet it doesn't seem to know how to
do very specialized Quantum field Theory
questions
generically I asked it
um you know I was told that it doesn't
have a social intelligence and that may
be but I asked that you know does this
query make my my ass look fat
it didn't want to answer it says I'm a
large language model it's an
inappropriate question I said what if I
was a husband asking being asked does
this dress make my ass look fat and it
says very often a woman is making this
query she's not asking for an actual
piece of information she's engaging in a
form of signaling as a test to see
whether the person is sensitive enough
to understand the reason as well as
being truthful enough to give credible
affirmation or something like this and I
thought okay well score one for the
computer now whatever those things are
you can now test to see this is real you
can ask it to do it in a language you
know that happens to be obscure the fact
that it made it concrete
means that we're no longer
arguing about whether this thing can
write a credible short story we know
that it can
wow so what does that mean for people
who want to be artists with people who
want to be creatives why do you want to
be an artist because I would say because
I have childhood tough childhood exactly
because art is an expression of the
human soul you can continue to express
the human soul the fact that a different
soul might Express itself in a way that
dwarfs your contribution you have to ask
yourself does that affect how you feel
about your own output
or for example uh if it writes a
beautiful love letter but you know that
it is soulless in your terms because
it's a bit of linear algebra with
non-linear function Theory thrown in
does that change the meaning the
poignancy of the words
what is a really moving lyric to you a
really moving lyric to me uh for
instance I think this is actually a
soccer manager said this Simplicity is
beauty so for instance uh
even though it was a cover but uh the
Motown song I Heard it Through the
Grapevine I know a man ain't supposed to
cry but these tears I can't hold inside
it's so simple and clean that song was a
failed song from multiple tries in fact
Barry gordier believes said that the
next person who mentions that song gets
fired Gladys Knight almost got that song
to the point of stardom because the Pips
had this thing where it's oh yes I am
yes it would Echo as it would get
fainter and fate or it was genius but it
wasn't as cool as when Marvin Gaye was
given the same song a half step or a
whole step above where he could sing so
he was forced to reach and stretch and
then you have the Halloween violins at
the beginning that set the tone for this
thing right and and what was it about
that song it's the fact that you've got
the minor sixth the fifth and the fourth
go you know uh do you plant let me go
before the other guy you knew before
what is it about that song is it the
breaking of The Voice or is it about the
particular aspects of the chord
progression
is it about the violins in the
background why did the song fail four
times before it actually succeeded you
have to ask yourself the questions you
could do that with any song and I would
have some sort of a similar story my
feeling about this is did you ever get
behind that song
did you ever wonder why it worked to me
I always put it down to the unique
beauty of Gay's voice which I think is
just heard it's stripped yes what do you
think of that I think it's phenomenal
phenomenal it's a revelation yeah yeah
what's your point Eric
I don't know whether it's the chord
progression which the thing can clearly
do or the fact that I believe that gay
is straining
and feeling what he's doing I don't know
whether it's the fact that this seems
like a human expression but he didn't
write the song
somebody else is there he animated the
song so it really has to do with the
context
okay and my claim is maybe this thing
will come up with a better lyric or a
better chord progression but it'll
matter less to you because it didn't
come from a human heart
I'm saying that you're gonna have to
start picking apart the essence of each
song or poem or story to figure out
whether you continue to feel that it's
art if it was written by linear algebra
okay
what if we go outside of the realm of R
and into the more practical and tangible
things yeah I mean you talk about the
end of capitalism and that makes sense
and if you look at what you know
communism or fascism or whatever they're
all responses to the economic
circumstances that they that they
encountered right so that they're a way
of trying to deal with the fact that
you've got an industrial revolution and
suddenly everyone goes into factories
and and now these people are there and
you they're now in cities and all and
all of it comes out of that right so
we're going to have to have a new
whatever a new whatever a new whatever
but
there's a lot of breaking that happens
first oh yeah
a lot of breaks sure I mean one of the
things that we haven't explored is my
need to work yeah
right
right because before purpose and meaning
for a lot of people so much work to do
that I never had to worry about my need
to work yes but when somebody says look
take the rest of your life off yeah you
know you can watch TV you can hang
around in the pool and suddenly uh
you know maybe your wife is looking at
you thinking you're kind of useless
I I kind of liked it better when uh he
was going out and killing mastodons and
dragging them back to my cave and now
you've got a new need which is okay
should we make some work for you that
doesn't need to be done should we find
you some busy work right that's
humiliating
so now that you've got a dignity
shortage you've got a purpose and
dignity shortage and what I'm saying is
assume that you had all of this work
removed from your shoulders
but you knew that you were going to die
on this planet because your water had
broken
when do you start getting excited about
breaking wildly new ground when do you
start thinking about taking fantastic
risks huge chances things that are are
noble enough to reacquaint ourselves
with the idea of a quest we're dead man
with there's this aspect when I listen
to as time goes by and it says it's
still the same old story of fight for
love and Glory I'm not allowed to say
Glory
I'm only allowed to say Glory if I
support Ukraine I get to say something
right because Slava means glory to
Ukraine I can't say glory to America so
we've been cut off
from our concept of questing and glory
and winning and Triumph and all of these
things because it's been associated with
the negative externalities of such
agreed yeah agreed so yes it's an
opportunity but not for everyone why do
you say that
if I look around at the world a lot of
people find themselves in jobs and
things that don't offer them any of that
such as
you know
checking tickets on a train you came
here on a train today I came here on a
train today
my guess is that somewhere somebody's
checking tickets on a train listening to
your podcast saying I love Eric I listen
to all of his stuff he I started buying
books on quantum theory a huge
percentage of my audience is plumbers
electricians long-haul truckers people
who solve problems every day they're
often not in highly repetitive tasks you
get called in to be an electrician or a
plumber in a house you've never been at
and it's got some set of problems you've
never encountered before
a lot of those people
are fit to be part of this Army and I
just think that actually we've got so
much human creativity that is stuck in
these jobs that we don't respect yeah
but I've learned to respect these jobs
so much more when I realized oh my God
my audience is studying Spinners and
differential operators in between uh you
know Uber assignments or something like
this is very interesting
hey Francis do you want to learn another
language no mate we voted brexit for a
reason well if you are open-minded
unlike Francis and want to learn another
language then Babel is the app for you
why would anyone want to learn that
foreign filth what's next eating snails
and frogs what kind of person goes
looking for food in the local pond dead
points for breakfast weird Babble makes
learning a language quick and easy
because it focuses on natural
conversation 15-minute lessons are
designed to be the most efficient and
effective way to learn a new language
lessons are created by over 150 language
experts meaning real people so not the
French so you learn how to have a real
world conversation things you'll
actually use not meaningless phrases
isn't even the word mate the great thing
about Babel is that the lessons are
interactive they aren't just robots
talking they're voiced by native
speakers using a modern conversation
based method so in no time you'll be
speaking confidently about real life
topics in another language with Babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including Spanish French
Italian and German even though that's
not a real language plus Babel speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your pronunciation and action in
next to no time you'll be speaking
German just like I speak English yeah
we're trying to sell the product mate
there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts Games videos or even
join live classes with a language
teacher start your new language learning
Journey with Babel today right now Babel
is off
go to babble.com play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months free
that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash play promo code
trigger Babel language learning that
works
what do we do with those people who for
whatever reason are not that way
inclined Eric who can't access these
type of Technologies or these type of
Industries because that's going to prove
a real problem well first of all why
don't we create some art for them that
excites them
why don't we use art to reacquaint
ourselves with the possible
I really feel like the artists have
fallen down on the job I feel like
today's art is in general not reflecting
our time and as a result it's becoming
less and less relevant and then people
get more and more adamant that no art
has never been more relevant because
they know that it's become less and less
relevant what do you mean by that that
it doesn't reflect our time let's let's
explore that okay so when the Erie Canal
was dug there were lots of songs about
the Erie Canal when the trains came in
there were lots of songs about trains
tell me that we don't have a million
songs about cars when people were
getting cars in the 1950s and they spoke
of Independence
all right
what are your favorite app songs
can anyone write a song about an app
Eric is an app gonna move you in order
to write a song about it there are apps
that govern your life right now
I know but my point is is that a great
artist that's what I mean it's hard time
yeah and changes it
uh into something that matters I asked
Sean Lennon why don't you write a song
that reflects our time and he wrote
Boomerang baby that was his attempt you
know she's never dated someone before a
thorough search of Google the only time
she's found in church is when attending
her own funeral you know it was speaking
to a Godless time where the apps were
fully integrated was that song highly
successful I don't know
you know but uh when Drake says you used
to call me on your cell phone he's
trying to take the fact that there is
some way you know are you going to swipe
right by me baby I don't know what that
lyric is it's hard
but then again the Erie Canal
you know it's not like it's the high
season oh the Erie he was a rising and
the Gin was getting low and I scarcely
think we'll get a drink till we get to
Buffalo you had to make that into
something
and so my feeling is all right it's
aren't up to the task of turning uh Waze
in Google Maps into something that I
care about is also the problem as well
when a lot of musicians have told me
this that to in order to write the idea
of a song that is a hit song has changed
like for instance a classic pop song is
around three minutes or two minutes 30
but now everything has to be designed
for tick tock so everything has to be
under a minute or 40 seconds and that's
completely transforming The Way We
Appreciate music I I heard the same
rumor uh I was discussing this uh with
Winston Marshall formerly of Mumford and
Sons the fact is that you had a snippet
that used this unusual phrygian
dominance scale
um which was uh
mommy don't know Daddy's getting hot at
The Body Shop doing something Unholy
just basically have a Nagila or misirlou
right and that lyric couldn't be
supported by the song because the song
couldn't sustain the interest that's no
way to live but on the other hand we
have a barbell of attention
we have the inability to get through a
longer tweet and the ability to watch
Game of Thrones with the longest
character developments anyone's ever
seen far dwarfing a movie and
approaching you know what you do in
spectacular fiction uh we have to
recognize that just as attention deficit
disorder actually contains the ability
to concentrate on something for months
you know with laser focus it's misnamed
we think that our attention spans have
shrunk to nothing no we're just really
easily bored by things that aren't
worthy of our attention at the moment
and it is changing our brains but if you
give me Game of Thrones I guarantee you
people be glued to their tubes and the
podcast in Revelation would certainly
speak to that long form I mean what is
it like when somebody says
oh man I'm only through my uh
second hearing of your four-hour uh Fest
on Rogan you're thinking you're in your
second hearing you're only through it
means you're going to do three
this is where we are and nobody nobody
understands this because the easy thing
to say is we got stupid and our
attention spans are shrinking to zero
but
it's it's Eric I'm so refreshed by what
you're talking about because one of the
things you've put your finger on is
we've lost I I don't want to put words
in your mouth so maybe help me out but
we've lost I mean is it self-belief is
it aspiration what is it what is it that
we what's your best story don't tell me
okay okay but you're now 93 years old
and it's getting close to to the end and
you're thinking about your life in terms
of your best stories you're watching
your children your grandchildren around
you and then you have a couple of
stories that are just the Glorious
stories of your youth think about
whether your best story is worthy of
your 93 years as it stands and my
feeling is that mine is not yet done
what is it that's worthy of your human
life why aren't we putting these stories
together right yeah right I couldn't
agree with you more I've been thinking
about this a lot
a lot on a personal level as you know as
we grow and we get opportunities that we
didn't have before and whatever
um but it's it's kind of it's weird we
don't talk about this stuff well we do
talk we do yeah we do we're trying so
people are starting people always want
to know why should I listen to you on a
podcast
I don't know you don't have to but we do
talk about this stuff and that's why
people tune in because there's something
ancestral
that says I'm not leading an archival
life worthy of being remembered when
when somebody says well when I write my
Memoirs are they going to be worth
reading
they might be worth writing
but what if they're worth writing it not
worth reading then you fail
think about what feynman's stories did
for people
for two books of basically
self-aggrandizing stories
that let people know oh my God it is
possible to have such an utree life a
life outside of the lines there's so
much of this world
that you can't get to if you never clear
your throat and you know you know one of
one of my favorite quotes from from me
people don't have to like it but I love
it
and it was hard to say the first time is
most of us die never having heard our
own voices
and
that's an epidemic yeah do you think as
well it's it speaks to the age that we
grew up in so I'll give the example of
my grandfather my grandfather was born
late 1920s my English grandfather in a
poor Working Class part of the north of
England he left school at 14 even though
he was very bright because there was no
other option he had to work when he left
school he went into what was essentially
the Great Depression
in the north of England so he used to
turn up with hundreds of people at the
dockyard in Liverpool the foreman would
come out and there'd be hundreds of men
in front of him he'd go you you the rest
of you [__] off right and then when he
got a job and he started to make his own
way and he was a joiner he was a
carpenter Master Joiner
then he was working uh for the the for
the mosquito Factory building the
mosquito the wooden plain
second world war he then joined in order
to fight he joined and he fought right
away from the top of Italy all the way
down to the bottom and then went to
North Africa and fought in the Battle of
El Alamein
on the Montgomery fought fighting
against rommel's Army he then returned
had a family raised his family
and when we talk about hardship now and
I'm not saying that people don't have it
tough of course they do and I'm not
saying they don't have difficulties
right but I look at my grandfather it's
that's a different human almost do you
see what I mean what he went through
yeah because he was catalyzed and in
part he may have said you know I we went
through life and death situations but we
didn't have your hardship of lack of
meaning I I think I did fix asphyxiate
if I had to lead your life
I mean you have to actually talk to some
of these people because some of them say
you know I'm not scared of of Bloodshed
or a life and death battle but I'm
terrified of being canceled online
you're thinking wait a minute you
actually served voluntarily in Iraq and
you're more afraid what would have so
what kills the spirit and what kills the
Flesh and what puts us at risk is
extremely variable but also just think
about this he had the ability to inspire
people I look at post World War II
Italian rock and roll
and it moves me because these people
turn their back on Mussolini you know
like when Renato Carson is saying to the
father Americano he's talking about the
passion for things American which are
sophisticated can you imagine anything
as accomplished as Italy
turning to America and saying hey you're
our style icons I mean it's it's
fantastic
and uh
you know have you ever heard um Adriana
talentano's um prison closing Catholic
yeah the song that is pure English
nonsense there's no actual English in it
um
and it's just it's it's just aping the
English language form showing that
people go crazy for it
those things came out
of American gi's
fighting through Italy
and
an admiration and a connection
you know and my feeling about this if
you don't have the ability to inspire
other people like that wow I'm not sure
that you're more fortunate
than your relatives
so
you said your favorite quote from you is
about most people die without
finding their voice or saying without
ever hearing their voice without ever
hearing their voice how do you find your
voice or he how do you get to the point
where you hear your voice
I can tell you how I do it but I don't
know that that's it well that's my point
right because I've had to find it for
myself as well right and maybe that's
what that's what you have to do maybe
it's the Journey of it I can't sing and
it have sort of sung on your show right
and people you're going to see in your
comments Eric thinks she's so cool right
and then you have to survive that
because otherwise you won't sing you
know one of the one of the things I love
is that as an extremely mediocre
non-guitarist who puts guitar stuff on
on on Instagram
some of the world's greatest guitarists
are like cheering me on in the comment
section and it's like the b-plus
guitarists were saying dude you can't
keep time you suck you know one more
Blues thing it's funny that people at
the top are always rooting for you and
people a couple levels under are always
trying to take the piss out of you my
feeling about it is is that you actually
have to do it and you open you know I
I've complained about homosexuals
monopolizing the closet
the closet is something where you open
the door and you don't necessarily say
I'm gay
you might open the door and say I think
the left has gone crazy or you might
open the door and say uh I think
conspiracy theories are actually quite
common and not very rare
and then you find out what happens after
that and you take the damage yeah so the
first thing is
the courage to do whatever is you
believe or you want to do or you want to
try well don't do it stupidly I mean you
have lots of things that you believe are
true that are just going to hurt people
aren't going to liberate aren't gonna so
for God's sakes keep most of the stuff
that you shouldn't say to yourself
some stuff in you than just
you can't live with it's just eating
away at you and then you know be very
careful make sure that you have a plan
for employment
because that's how they get most of us
is that we're wage slaves
and think about am I comfortable dying
always having been careful not to say
anything that would rock the boat
because if you're comfortable with that
if that's okay because this is the only
time you you get to do this
that that's your choice
but you know as I was just talking to
somebody who had been canceled and
canceled is really misunderstood the
people you meet after cancellation blow
your mind totally yeah completely you
know it's like I never wrote on a
private plane until I've been
you know
you know we were talking about song
lyrics and one of them the one that
always sticks out for me is that song I
can never remember the name of the song
but it's from the musical La Casio fall
which goes life ain't worth a damn until
I can say I am what I am
if that's what is in you then yeah but I
will point out that a lot of people are
being induced to be what what they're
not and then being asked to sing that
song and so one of the things that we're
very cautious about
is that there are all sorts of Fringe
freak movements that are trying to push
people into extreme behavior and then
you know announce who they are to the
world and make sure that it is who you
are and not that you've joined something
that really wants to to have you do that
and what all these movements Eric well
for example the go go broke issue is uh
you have somebody who has decency and
goodness in them and then they're seized
upon by a cult you know of undergoing a
group mental disease and then it's like
Proclaim Proclaim your hatred for uh you
know the market or something like this
or you know glue your hand to a painting
yeah that's not that inspiring if you
want to protest something I tell
everybody uh don't throw soup on Van
Gogh
what you want to do is try projection
mapping put in a huge amount of work
take a building with a complicated
facade map it on a computer design a
brilliant animation roll up on a
moonless night and project your
animation that puts a forward your
political perspective on that facade of
a building for a minute take a video of
it and leave you won't have hurt
anything that anyone else has built
you'll have owned and monopolized
something you could do it with CIA
headquarters you know you could do it
with uh you know with the Lincoln
Memorial
uh but show that you're clever you've
put in a ton of work you're extremely
creative and that you care without
calling attention to yourself like an
ass
but that's hard Eric isn't this the
whole point I mean a lot of all of this
stuff no I'm serious I know this is the
point I made something hard of course
but this is the point I made in my
Oxford speech is like the reason that
these people do glue themselves to roads
and throw soup on paintings and so on
it's because it's easy it's because you
you can be a brain dead [__] and do it
the mom and the moment and our mutual
friend Melissa Chen I think this is one
of her quotes she said you cannot remain
woke while building things whether
that's muscle whether that's a career
whether that's a business whether you
can't because it requires you to
confront the reality and the complexity
of the world why is there only one
Melissa chat we don't know right it's
like really mysterious that there are so
few people
who so many of these ideas come from
yeah and so my point is we just said I
just said for the nth time go learn
projection mapping and nobody basically
does it occasionally somebody will take
a piece of text and project it onto a
building and I'm just thinking
in your day job maybe you're doing this
for Adidas or Nike you know
go be a real pirate
and do it for your environmental cause
for your issue about uh you know hanging
homosexuals in Iran you know do
something Noble that's hard and inspire
people
it will still not happen people are
self-attenuating this is Marty
sulligan's theory of learned
helplessness we have to figure out how
can you start small and create and to
your point
um or maybe I'm talking to Melissa
through you
once you build things you don't
necessarily lose your idealism
no you lose your wokeness as a surface
level yes
climate is still an issue for what
reasons that I do not understand we lie
about climate in the direction that
climate is actually going so we people
have the illusion
that climate is not a problem at all
because if it were a problem we wouldn't
be lying about it but we're lying about
it in the direction we're trying to make
it as simplified tell us more about that
Eric
it seems to me very clear that
scientific consensus is being
manipulated by official bodies to get
certain narratives to do things
as some of us spot the fact that the
scientific consensus is being
manipulated we get the idea oh whoever's
the manipulator is lying because it's
not true as opposed to lying because we
have to actually make things simplified
in order to get political change or we
don't know why we're being lied to there
are plenty of reasons people lie both in
your interests and against your
interests so the epidemic of lying has
created a general sense that
um
whatever is being lied about is untrue
you know covid really wasn't a problem
as if many people didn't die
you know one of the reasons that I
thought the vaccines was really
interesting was that I felt very clear
that kovid's Origins were being lied
about because to say that you can't ask
whether something came from a lab
because it's racism was the only thing I
knew was total BS
I don't know whether it came from a wet
Market I think it didn't I think it
probably came from a lab but I what I
didn't know about was whether the
vaccine was being we were being lied to
because we knew it was a bio weapon and
this vaccine was intended to mitigate
the long-term 10-year effects of a
bioweapon like AIDS doesn't show up
initially as a huge problem when you get
infected with HIV it's a long time
before it really you know the
coposarcoma starts so I think we're just
really confused because we've been lied
to so many times we're punched drunk and
as a result we just don't know what
we're advocating for I don't know how
big a problem climate is I know it's a
problem
I don't know how big I don't know what
we actually know
I've been confused so my the variance in
my opinion about how big of a problem
this is and whether it commands The
Lion's Share of my attention or not
uh I don't know because I've just lost
faith and trust in the ipcc then that's
a very real problem when we don't have
faith in our institutions that means
we're we're at a point of Crisis can I
just push back on this ever so slightly
of course you can absolutely
when we say we don't have faith in our
institutions what the heck are we
talking about like I got on a plane to
come here
if you think about the de Havilland
comment it crashed all the time
planes don't crash anymore they used to
those are institutions that are keeping
the same people who lose your luggage
and who delay and over book you make
sure that your plane doesn't crash
and so you're having a weird Association
I can't trust the Airlines and I totally
trust the airline you trust the airline
to screw up your flight to overcharge
you to overbook you to do all this stuff
and you trust them absolutely with your
family and your life
to take off on a death trap filled with
jet fuel from one situation not knowing
the weather somewhere else
and land
we do trust our institutions and we
don't and we do and we don't and it's
making us crazy well that's the worst
thing right if we just didn't trust them
that would be a lot easier it's the it's
this ambiguity it's Schrodinger's
[__] yes
and and this is what's making us mad the
cheap thing to say is I can't trust the
institutions that's right
the weirdest thing to say is I don't
understand why they're so good and so
bad simultaneously that's right why
aren't they so good and so bad
simultaneously
um I think because
there's a centralized reason why they
they started screwing up which is this
theory of embedded growth obligations
what's that telling we have no idea what
that is
from 1945 where World War II seals in an
order from a really decisive Victory up
until
1968 through 73. it's not WTF happened
in 71 as the Bitcoin it's sort of 68.73.
that period of broad
distributed
technologically LED Dependable high
levels of growth deranged us we thought
that was our future
and we built a society in a world that
required that level of growth
and sometimes you have an organism that
has multiple life cycles
a guy named Mark tashney wrote a book
called the genetic switch about the fact
that uh
T4 bacteriophage Lambda phage Lambda has
two different lives that can lead and I
think in part the West has two different
lives it can lead it can lead a high
growth life uh life cycle or it can lead
a low growth life cycle when we say we
don't recognize ourselves and are we the
same people who won World War II or
something like that we don't recognize
that that is one of our potential life
cycles nobody had ever seen the low
growth Western
life cycle and it's terrifying it's it's
us eating each other
I must grow my slice of the pie just the
way my great grandfathers grew their
slice of the pie and the only way I can
do that if the pie isn't growing fast
enough is to eye your slice
so I'm looking at your slice and
suddenly we each appear to each other
not as a source of inspiration but as a
source of protein and nourishment
and that's but that's
that's response isn't it Eric well it's
a realistic response in other words if
I'm doing something that's growth based
and if I suffused all of these
institutions with certain growth
obligations the portion of that
institution like its pension fund that
had to grow at a level that it cannot
grow at become psychopathic
right is that why we print endless money
that we don't have and borrow from our
grandchildren
yes
in essence what happened was north of
Bretton Woods collapsing and the removal
of the gold standard it was the loss of
technological change in fuel
that came easily in the 20th century so
there are all sorts of disasters in the
20th century but there are all sorts of
Marvels
and when those started to dry up which
essentially came from something I've
called umvelt hacking that you could see
more and more with scientific
instrumentation so you could look into
the cell at some point you have to guess
it with the three-dimensional structure
of DNA was at some point you could
basically look at
right so we started to get into a place
where we couldn't sustain the science
the science couldn't detain sustain the
technology the technology couldn't
sustain the markets and everything had
been built with an obligation
so the whole point of this theory of
egos or embedded growth obligations is
how do we have a theory why all
institutions would sort of get into
trouble at once
and it's the common thing is growth that
can't be met
right so that's that's why everything
went funny now that's not to say that
we're not analytic if we didn't want to
lie to keep this game going
um we could fix a lot of things so
things that do get fixed are things like
uh
airplane checklists to make sure that we
don't take off with something broken the
checklist is also operative in a
hospital so you don't amputate the wrong
leg so the the explosion in iatrogenics
which is that harms done by harm done by
physicians to their own patients and the
epidemic of crashes that ended both in
part result from a common uh
understanding and management that a
checklist is a life-saving thing
we could do that with Integrity to
the growth based Parts the pension I
could say to you actually you know these
commitments we made to to your pension
can't be met
um here's what's realistic and here's
what's safe what do you guys how do you
guys feel about two percent or you know
or 1.5 growth you say well can I retire
not really very well
you might paid my whole life into
helping other people yeah you're part
you're you're the loser in the pyramid
scheme how do you feel
well you don't feel good that's the part
I have to start lying about right I've
been thinking about this a lot man
because
um
that's really
every every time I I haven't been able
to work out up until this conversation
why every time there's a crisis
no one says we we have a limited amount
of money no one ever says that uh it's
like in this country the com the NHS is
always underfunded every you know if if
the electricity prices or gas prices go
up the government has to support people
right and I know who could disagree with
that well and tell me something how many
of these people know the word senior age
no do you no no
senior age is the tax
on the holders of money
that they experience when you print more
of it
right so in essence
when the money supply goes up and you
say you know we really need
um to do something about uh monetary
policy in order to alleviate the
pressure
you're really saying we need to tax the
holders of money
by printing more of it so you're raising
money through senior age then you have
like all of these other things a really
bizarrely explained like a stock market
crash
stocks fell today in a precipitous
decline over the last three hour trading
hours that's not what happened at all
the right way of saying it is the dollar
surged against equities
or the pounds surged against the footsie
you know and what is it you've got this
amazing and beautiful numerator which is
an index fund let's say
500 stocks for the s p but what's your
denominator oh it's the dollar it's one
instrument and that one instrument is
further disguised by being called the
numerator it's the measuring step
so now you're playing games with a
rubberized measuring stick and when the
measuring stick moves that's what caused
all the equities to apparently fall it's
it's not the price of equities it's an
exchange rate with another instrument
and the other instrument surged
so what we do is we keep you in a
Perpetual state of stupidity
so and the reason that they do that is
because if they're honest
that will precipitate a loss of
confidence and if there's a loss of
confidence then the whole thing
collapses like the cut house of cards
that it is well correct and you don't
want a complete loss of confidence you
want theater you want [__] you want
belief but you want a higher level adult
level you want an adult level of fiction
these fictions are dangerous
unsustainable
you know there's a French philosopher
Jamie charteris told me this and it
changed my life he said a nation is
defined to be a group of people who have
agreed to forget something in common
and you have to understand the purpose
of of nonsense of theater of BS of
aspiration
the U.S had some of the best of this
stuff
all men being created equal when you
held slaves
it wasn't true it was honored only
initially in the breach
but it was open-ended and it gave the
opportunity when you had the opportunity
to get rid of your slavery to promote
something to all men truly being equal
and then we get the things like this oh
what is it the idiot 1619 project where
we replace one brilliant set of fictions
with a completely ridiculous set of
fictions that are not sustainable
right what is a 69 1619 project the idea
being you've agreed to forget something
in common you didn't include us you
oppressed us completely you're telling
this offensive story this is the part
I'm sympathetic with with the 1619. you
can't leave out Black America
from its own part of the founding of the
country you have to create a better
newer fiction fine but the idea that
you're gonna like just try to destroy
the founding fathers of the country the
national governing narrative and you're
going to try to make people hate the day
they were born for singing the national
anthem I don't know who came up with the
idea that this woman Nicole Hunter Jones
was fit to refound the country it's
Madness and craziness
the issue is
we need to be decent and better and
she's right about all sorts of things
but she's wrong about leading
and so by Leading what do you mean by
that by Leading how do we come up with
an inclusive fiction
that we can all subscribe to where our
common purpose is to build that fiction
into reality
what was wrong with MLK's fiction
pretty great that's what I think yeah
but
well you know it's the same thing MLK
was drawing from Gandhi for example most
people think Gandhi was a pacifist
Gandhi hated pacifism with passion you
cannot imagine
he had a hierarchy
oh yeah Gandhi was really pro-violence
and anti-pacificism and he's very clear
on this if you read it
his point was non-violence is the
highest level of Courage possible and
almost nobody has that ability because
what is it it's a pre-commitment to
martyrdom to screw your opponent these
opponent who does not understand that
they can kill you and you will not raise
your hand to defend yourself is walking
into a trap
Gandhi was about martyrdom and you want
to look at the courage of somebody like
John Lewis you know Crossing that bridge
down south
I mean my understanding is Malcolm X was
not courageous enough to March alongside
Dick Gregory in MLK because those guys
were so effing hardcore they were
willing to die for their cause and they
were willing to be martyred for their
cause
Gandhi's second level below non-violence
was violence and he said if you don't
have the stones to for non-violence
please pick up a gun
please engage in violence because the
thing I detest is pacifism
so we don't have a story that goes along
with that
would you say about MLK so MLK has this
vision
but MLK's Vision was based on Gandhi and
he was selling it as if it was much less
hardcore than it actually was
in civil rights
was purchased with infinite heroism
and you know that's why Dick Gregory is
my personal I almost can't talk about
you know this comedian
um he committed that if he and his wife
were taken into a police station in the
south
and she was nine months pregnant with
one of his kids and the sheriff was
kicking her pregnant belly he wouldn't
do anything
and they said our
our cause is more important than our
marriage in our own lives
so what was wrong with it it required
too much
we didn't get how amazing these people
were
and particularly when we live in an era
where we're encouraged ever more to
think about ourselves in an era which is
ever more atomized so people
will be less likely to Martyr themselves
for a cause if they think they're the
most important thing there is if there's
somatic cells
we're leading somatic lives these people
weren't leading somatic lives what does
that mean Eric somatic lives so your
cells in your body are divided into Soma
and germ your ear is not going to
reproduce itself even though it has all
this genetic information but your gonads
have different properties right your
reproductive stuff is what gets cancer
early in life where there's all the
other stuff gets cancer late in life
so the issue is are you into somatic
pleasure
or are you into having babies and
perpetuating this this thing and tying
our pleasure
to our fitness and by Fitness as my
brother points at it's about a lot it's
about lineage
and
it's very hard when people no longer
believe in religion they don't believe
in
multi-generational strategies to tell
them
yeah your summer matters but you're
overdoing it
yeah it that is a very difficult thing
to tell people particularly when our
society is focused on Pleasure
well but when you've given up on the
future implicitly right you've given up
on the future
and my feeling is
if you're not excited about the future
that quote about Society functions when
old men plant trees under her shade they
will never sit
that broke and if I can call out one
person who who really pisses me off it's
Rachel Maddow
Rachel manow was invited as a guest
to give an award for women in science at
Rockefeller University
and the moment that I completely broke
with
the sort of woke vision of the left
was she shows up at Rockefeller
University sort of almost a secret
facility because it has no undergraduate
so we don't even realize that it's there
but a Powerhouse of biomedical research
and there are multiple Nobel laureates
who have called this home and they're
pictures and and very accomplished
people are up on the wall and it happens
that most of those people are probably
white of Hugh and male
and she looks up and she says what is up
with the dude wall
and the pictures come down
and I have this feeling of who is this
woman
who is this woman
in our house
what did she do
what did she accomplish
does she understand
s for RNA
does she know what a vaccine is does she
have any knowledge of sex and bacteria I
mean who is this person she's a
presenter
and I wish to be good hosts
but there is a moment when you let
somebody into your home who is
completely empty of the generosity of
spirit that lives under your roof
and you have to say uh it seems to be
getting late
um perhaps I should call you a cab
right but isn't it the fault of the
owner of the house that they don't do
that to her
I believe she became the owner of the
house
you know there are stories in India
where my wife is from where somebody
comes and visits a home and says
that painting is magnificent and what is
that what does the family do give it
away they said really it's been
cluttering up our wall for forever
please take it you'd be doing us a favor
so the American walks out with bags full
of stuff saying those are such nice
people
and the family when the door closes oh
my
taking and taking and taking
because it's a cultural misunderstanding
yes
right and my feeling is is that the
people who let Rachel Maddow into
Rockefeller University
we're acting in beautiful good faith
were they
or were they afraid this is what I
increasingly Wonder because that's a
metaphor for institutions more broadly
right
were they though or were they just
afraid because increasingly that's my I
hear the ugliness of my own speech
constantly I hear my phrase who are you
and what are you doing in my lab
right but that's exactly the right
question isn't it yes but when they came
from my brother
at Evergreen yeah and I was calling up
um
you know newspapers will you write this
story nobody until Barry Weiss wrote the
story would write that story the only
person I could even get to understand
this thing before somebody you had in
this chair who you know a great deal of
damage was done Mr Sam Harris Sam Harris
courageously waded into something he did
not understand what was going on in
Evergreen nobody understood this woke
mind virus and figured out Barry and Sam
were two of the very first people to
even get what this risk was
and by the way we've got to take people
who stumble in these interviews and who
make mistakes and have blind spots and
who do things that we don't like but
basically show courage
and integrity we've got to stop blaming
them for the tiny bit they can't see I
agree I completely agree the first thing
we did when that whole thing went crazy
was contact time to make sure he was
okay it was never Our intention to end
up the way that what happened I'm glad
you said that actually and there'll be a
bunch of idiots in the comments uh
getting upset with you but I couldn't
agree with you more I always consider
reducing your follower account when you
have the app oh that's what we always do
yeah uh we always do and I I want to get
it on the record that while I think what
Sam said was wrong which it was which it
was uh I did not enjoy even a moment of
the backlash that happened and you know
you guys have been trying to get me to
come on this podcast for a while and it
was after that happened that I decided I
really wanted to do it so anyway so Sam
Harris
but also as well you know there'll be
times when I'm walking through London
they'll be like oh it's a trigonometric
or it's Francis and now oh you got Sam
Harris didn't you and every time someone
says that to me I cringe because this
show is not about getting people it's
about exploring ideas and I brought it
up because you guys needed the
opportunity to say it yeah yeah well
thank you so
let's come back to the growth thing
because I feel like we're we've for at
least for me we've got our finger near
the button yeah this is the big story
right
so in some ways the crazy loons are
right in the infinite growth finite
resources it's not going to happen
yes and no I mean the growth can't be so
much of our growth is basically been in
correlation with how much fossil fuel
you can burn exactly that has to break
in a different form of growth has to
occur which is how many ideas per unit
of non-sustainable energy you know you
can create so the growth has to be in
some sense idea based
yeah
but again you can also potentially try
to architect the system that doesn't
have the same crazy needs for growth
that has a plan
for when growth is naturally present
when growth is absent we should be
sitting around talking about what is the
new economics instead what we're talking
about is
how do we keep communism at Bay while
capitalism is struggling and my feeling
is
Tweedle them and Tweedle D you may have
a preference between the two of them but
everything is telling you innovate in a
new economic market-based system if you
care about Freedom human potential and
we have people who are just stuck
on capitalism is the part of the problem
as well Eric and look I'm in favor of
democracy this is not an argument Pro
autocracy I want to make that absolutely
clear before I say but don't we need a
dictator
but you know when you have like yes
but uh when you have um you know the
Democratic model four or five years it
that encourages short-termism doesn't it
in that all people are worried about is
winning that next election
what I'm trying to say to you is you're
being invited to a much bigger
conversation that no one has attended
which is what is the positive Port of
democracy into a 22nd century framework
correct so what is it what's the new
economic model Eric what are you talking
about I've tried to talk about it tell
us look at my thing about the new
gimmick economy right and where I'm
trying to talk about the fact that
you're going to have to deregulate a
tiny number of people who are absolutely
powerhouses on generative far-right tail
behavior and you're gonna have to
unshackle them
and then you're going to have to somehow
force a spreading of wealth in this
deregulated system
you're going to have to recognize that
the output of different human beings
based on the kurtosis of how people are
distributed
has to be embraced so what does that
look like in real world terms Eric you
probably shouldn't be telling Elon Musk
that he's not invited to the electric
vehicle Summit at the White House Long
you know get over yourselves
um Elon and you know I've been super
critical of you know on a lot of
different things is a Next Level human
being at some level he's also a [__]
artist he's a master showman he's a
troll
he fakes things
he's a genius he's a scoundrel I mean
he's not there's a lot going on with
Elon and what I'm trying to say is
you're going to have to start dealing
with super complicated generative people
I worked for Peter Thiel for 10 years
almost
Peter's a genius he's an out and out
genius and he's a better communist than
most communist he's got the ability to
run communism in his mind
he can run capitalism and libertarianism
and anything else
you're gonna have to start stop
demonizing these people in these
completely simplistic terms you're gonna
have to invite a lot of freaks and
Weirdos according to normies
to dance and play and build and think
and you're gonna have to stop
making their lives a living hell it's
one of the things I've been thinking
about a lot we confuse
wealthy people with successful people
and we taught them all with one brush
and we say if you've got money you're
evil
well
here's the really interesting news a lot
of these people tolerate people with
radically different politics Peter Thiel
and I have radically different politics
we can also finish each other's
sentences at times
you know
the world of remarkable people
needs to be more Unshackled
and more people need to be invited in
case they are also remarkable and they
come from circumstances where it wasn't
identified
you know my belief is
and I'll save this maybe towards the end
but
you need to go after your learning
disabled people
because a lot of those people are the
innovators that you desperately need
right now
you're making their lives a living hell
you're making School a daily exercise
and having your head shoved in the
toilet and a lot of those people are
super Learners that you're pretending
you're learning disabled
um
we need a new economic model that is
based on the tiny number of people who
can perform in these completely crazy
circumstances we need to make their
lives great
and we need also
to come up with a culture of service
you know which is really weird but you
don't get to keep your wealth
if all you're doing is enjoying luxury
and posting pictures on Instagram about
you know I drove my Aston Mark Martin to
get to my Bentley to get to my Gulf
Stream
that's your lifestyle you you failed you
know the key thing is is that
serve others you have to serve you have
you just Bob Dylan got it right you have
to serve somebody and a culture of
service of obligation
I was just at a kind of a secret meeting
of incredible people in London
billionaires at the table in general I
said you know at some point somebody
called on me you know and
was a peer and
said Eric has something to say I didn't
really have something to say but one of
the things I said is I just listened
to you all talking behind closed doors
about the need to help those less
fortunate
nobody would believe that that's what
you're actually talking about behind
closed doors
right and
you have to open your houses invite
people to dinner to dine with you I just
had this thing with Billy Bragg where I
ran into a festival
took the piss out of me in a book and on
social media
and I said why don't we share the stage
and sing a song together and he said
what are you doing on my stage I'm not
going to share this you know but when I
meet him over coffee
you know we're able to bridge things
come together and the issue is we need
to do some things where people you never
imagine would break bread or share a
stage
do so because this is an emergency
situation so open your homes invite
people in show people what it is that's
your actual tradition it's very hard for
an anti-semite to survive a Shabbat
dinner
and I I completely agree with you on
all that you were saying particularly
when it comes to education somebody who
was a teacher for many years I saw what
we did to the neurologically atypical
I'm neurologic atypical myself and it's
you're kidding me
but how else do we unshackle potential
how else do we unleash this ball of
creativity
thank you
stop with uh
how do I put this
look at the troll section on Reddit
it's this giant group of people telling
other people you know that thing you
believe in I saw through it a long time
ago it's like nobody can believe
anything we're in this sort of I don't
know it's like a an orgy of
not believing of nihilism
if you don't believe in anything you
lost like look it's all Bs for sure it
made me sound and Furious signifying
nothing but if that's the answer you
came up with you just lost life
um I think what we have to do is we have
to put forward a positive Vision where
we're starting to talk about yeah you
can see when you when you come up with a
song lyric I'm in your song I'm feeling
I'm thinking it
show people what's possible show people
how to take anything
cup of coffee you know the the story of
Robusta versus arabica beans or you know
we we could take the light in this room
and the fact that I keep talking about
there's a Secret Circle at every point
in space and time otherwise we wouldn't
be able to see each other we don't tell
anybody about so they keep talking to us
about Schrodinger's cat but they don't
even understand the beauty of Maxwell's
equation the world is just overflowing
with beauty and majesty and
Transcendence and we're caught talking
about who thinks how much of themselves
and who's self-promoting and who's who's
a [__] for clicks and all of this stuff
it's all socially based and I think what
we need to do in part is to
do cool stuff
some at some point the first person is
going to pull off this projection
mapping thing as a protest and it's
going to inspire the world and I won't
have to explain it again I'll just point
people to the video so whoever you are
out there gonna address the camera if
you're upset about the way in which
we're burning oil
or if you're upset about inequality
consider projection mapping and
inspiring everybody put a lot of work
into it do a killer animation join a
team of people who do this for corporate
learn the trade and then go radical go
Rogue and be a pirate and don't hurt
people in the process it's so simple to
do new things I don't know why we're not
I I think it's because it's it's all
fair it's all fair that holds us back
itself
it's that because this is something that
I've I've learned through my own
experiences of doing this show through
you know falling and losing French
friends etc etc we are terrified of
being alienated from the tribe we are
terrified of standing out because as you
know
thousands of years ago that meant
certain death but we've been programmed
that way so I think what happens a lot
Eric is that a lot of the time people
are scared to be authentic people are
scared to say what they truly think and
feel people are scared to live the life
that they truly want because it would
mean in part that they risk alienation
from the tribe it's a really interesting
point let's assume that those fears are
reasonable valid and evolutionarily
based
let's try a different fear they're
slightly less than 5 000 weeks in a life
think about that fear right one more
just went by
right come up with with a jar with like
5 000 sweets in it or something and just
take one out every week and watch the
odds that you're ever going to
accomplish anything or do anything or
Inspire somebody
you know go down and further and further
why don't you put it off another two
weeks or three weeks so why don't we
start this in September
that's right you know that's right
that's the way that's the way and that's
how I think about it uh that's how I
think about it Francis is right that a
lot of people
fear that and I also think we talked
about it earlier you know doing hard
things is hard and people prefer to do
easy things but you're right
um I think when and this is you know we
haven't talked about God and maybe we
don't have time or maybe we'll do it in
on on the local section but
you I take a lot of inspiration from the
fact that life is finite a lot of
inspiration
how old are you 40.
I take a lot of inspiration from that uh
because this is it right here and you
either make the most of it you don't
every day that's it and to me Eric part
of the reason why we had why we went
insane over covert and I use that word
accurately because we did go insane we
lost we lost something still
insane okay and and I take your point
but the reason for me is because
we have lost we no longer accept the
fact that we are going to die we don't
talk about it it's a taboo in
particularly in Western Nations and you
see that with our celebrities with their
weird smooth plastic lizard faces right
because nobody wants to admit their
aging nobody wants to admit they're
getting older nobody wants to admit that
there is an end to this
so that being the case why would you
endure a moment of discomfort in this
life is this this is literally all you
have
isn't it Samurai I want to understand
this sorry say more I wanna so so why
would you if this is all we have if if
this life is all you've got why would
you make it unpleasant why would you
make it difficult why would you make it
because there's something eating at your
soul
because because there's a worm inside
your body whittling you out from the
inside and causing you to die a little
bit more every day you think you're
gonna die at age 90 no no that's the
final death
I told my grandfather I said there's a
last time you do everything and you
don't realize when that is
you know I crossed the great Himalayan
range when I was 20 or something on foot
I thought I would be doing it regularly
that may be the only time I ever crossed
the great Himalayan range on foot my
ankle Now isn't as good as it used to be
think about the last time you went
backpacking and actually slept out under
the stars for all I know that part of
you was already dead now figure out how
much death you can actually handle in a
living body
and figure out maybe you want to reclaim
some of that right maybe you want to
reclaim that through having children
maybe you want to reclaim that through
their eyes you take an ice cream cone
boy that ice cream cone looks good to
you you only have one of them you can
have you could feed it to your kid
you're going to taste that ice cream
cone so much more if you give it to your
kid
because his tea is just an ice cream
cone right there's a weird way in which
I just think that we're not we're not
figuring out how Grand this adventure is
and to your point about covet
I don't even know how to talk about this
I could use some help there's a meaning
crisis the people who don't feel
comfortable talking about religion and
I'm not a religious person I'm an
atheist
the meaning of life has gone away you
can see an amazing band at a concert it
just doesn't mean what it used to mean
we have better guitarists right now than
we've ever had
and they don't mean as much as they
meant in the 70s when we were having
idiotic arguments whether Clapton Paige
or Hendricks was the greatest guitarist
of all time
I don't know what's going on with this
things are not attaching in the sense of
meaning
the greatest quote and I'm searching for
it everywhere somebody out there held me
there was a woman in a doors documentary
who said the words back then we didn't
realize it was just music
I can't tell you how profound that was
to me the idea was she later realized it
was just music
for a period of time she was able to
attach that feeling of meaning of
transcendence of permanence of something
to something she was experiencing at the
Whiskey A Gogo on the Sunset Strip
we can't attach that feeling of meaning
almost at all there's something about
the phone that has rewired our brain we
call it a phone even though mostly we
don't call anybody on it we go back and
forth between a screen and a person's
screen and a person it rewires our minds
and in the end we can't feel our own
children or we can't remember our first
kiss I don't know what's going on with
that yeah so for me I feel see I still
think music is is more than just music
I've always felt that and I'm not
musically gifted in any shape or form if
I started singing you would all leave
the room immediately do you want to try
no yeah I want people to carry on
watching this interview right no no no
you're going to lead over there but I
don't want you to
I'm not going to push you this thing
yeah
but isn't it weird that we decide that
dance is for people who can move
properly music is for people who can hit
a note
people say I don't play an instrument
one thing I learned from
you know the uh
sort of the Gypsy tradition
you know you can make noise just by
puffing air into your cheeks and
changing the tension in your cheeks so
they always have an instrument they're
never without
right and uh
it just moves me the fact that we're so
alienated from dancing from music that
we sit around worrying about what
everybody else is gonna think
yeah you're right
keep going so
but to me the one of my favorite
playwrights is uh you you part of me
it's called David Mamet sure and David
Mammoth wrote a book called true and
false which was about acting but it
wasn't really about acting it was more
than that it was about art it was about
life it was about how the life of an
artist is but is one of the most
profound things that you can have and
that you can Embrace and he said
something very simple
but he said words that come from the
heart go to the heart
and and maybe this is me this is me
being nostalgic this is me projecting
but
there's a lot of time now where I just
feel when I listen to modern music
it doesn't seem to have the heart
because when someone is honest with you
you know they don't need to use the most
verbose language it doesn't need to be
poetic it doesn't need all these trick
tricks and tips and whatever else it can
be as simple as I know a man ain't
supposed to cry but these tears I can't
hold inside and the mum you listen to it
you go bam I know that I felt that
because we've all felt that particularly
being men right
it's interesting I remember watching
Jack White talking about Sun house who
could play guitar but there's a moment
where Sun house is on stage on film
and he's singing John the Revelator I
don't know if you know the song who's
that right in John the Revelator and
he's clapping on one and three and he's
stomping on two and four right that's it
you know one in three being broken out
from two and four and that sort of
repetitive pocket that just grabs you
and holds you
there is some of that music being made
and some of it is weird as hell yeah I
really looked at Tim Henson's polyphia
and goat and you look at that and it's
sort of like almost Havana unana some
sort of Tex-Mex Caribbean Cuban thing
but filtered and sharded and shattered
and broken and healed back together
there is some way in which Bonnie Vera's
Creek
you know the the it's like what Cher did
with auto-tune to believe where she took
something that was Pitch adjustment she
turned it into an instrument before
T-Pain never got to this that thing
which is the alienation in our time and
the electronics and the heart and the
soul and the alienation and the need for
closeness you know whatever these things
are that speak to us what is it about
Green Day's good riddance that made it
blow up like that you know the fact that
you could feel the the
sand going through your hourglass
you know or you know maybe one of the
best of these things anticipating social
media and the internet and all of the
cancellation was Iris by the Goo Goo
Dolls with those lyrics that ended up on
so many high school yearbook Pages you
know I don't want the world to see me
because I don't think that they'd
understand that's about cancellation
before cancellation is a thing
right and so these things that speak to
us that
if we had more of them
it would mean more and the thing about
it is I can point you to some of the
things that are happening now
that matter to me I know that I'm not
dead I know that I'm not an old man
saying get off my lawn
the problem is it's very hard to say
something changed in music Rick biato a
friend of mine from Atlanta has this
channel Everything music and he talks
about the decrease in the complexity of
music
you don't see the sort of Steely Dan
phenomena or Frank Zappa was effectively
a classical composer as my son points
out to me in a rock and roll idiom doing
the most complicated and complex music
about something
he points out that the Frank Zappa's
titties and beer is actually an homage
to Stravinsky we don't have these Super
Rich interlinkings between pieces of Art
you know I often talk about uh you know
April is the coolest month is a lyric is
a as a lyric as a as a line from T.S
Eliot is evoking the fact that school
children used to be taught the Middle
English one that the pill with the sure
so the beginning Chaucer's Canterbury
Tales this interlinking world of
references of meaning to the Discovery
the Easter eggs that are hidden
everywhere
is gone it is and part of that is and
I've seen it myself because when I went
to school I was lucky enough to be
taught poetry and I remember we had to
learn a poem and we had to stand up and
we had to say and as a kid I was like
why do I have to get up and say William
Blake's the entire class these words
don't mean anything to me they don't
convey anything it's just boring it's
just empty recital but it isn't because
Blake is one of our greatest ever poets
and thinkers and artists and by
listening to those words by ingesting
them by literally making them part of
you there's also the weaponization of
taste the idea The Taste is not
discussable
that we can't say that certain taste is
better than others because I see your
taste and I want to take you from where
you are to where you were meant to be
not necessarily to where I am because my
taste is different
these are things that require High Trust
you have to trust that in fact you can't
analyze the complexity of a song you can
say what its harmonic structure is and
it's not all about get off my my lawn or
all old people always think those things
I could tell you about things that I
think are incredibly complex and
Brilliant that I don't like
and what we're seeing is the
simplification the language change where
we're starting starting to have a name
for Bernie bro or Tech bro
or a reply guy or pick me girl
you know Creator and content are the two
things if I could I would banish from
the English language because what it is
is you know should do you want food
thank you food is good I enjoyed your
food
oh what kind of food
yeah but High Rocky is a problem now
tell me the idea of hierarchy is a
problem a hierarchy of I mean you're
talking about content some content is
good some content's bad you can't it's
difficult to have any conversation that
involves hierarchy for a lot of people
so what should I do yeah
I mean that's my life yeah I know and
you should carry on doing it yeah yeah
not only that Eric you should carry on
doing it on locals with us because
that's where we're gonna go
Segway very much we're running out of
time sorry about that no no don't be
sorry about that it's a pleasure before
we go there and ask the questions that
our audience have submitted and there's
some really good ones by the way
um what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
well the most important thing is we're
not talking about
and I'll combine the two things into one
thing so that I actually fit your
question
we need to be getting people who are
learning disabled not marked as learning
disabled marked as super Learners making
sure that they have wonderful lives as
scientists particularly getting them to
focus on longevity
and on physics for the purpose of
diversifying our human habitats to
having more than one atmosphere learning
that this is not science fiction until
we find the ultimate Theory every Theory
Beyond Einstein may have possibilities
to Traverse the cosmos that the current
theories indicate is impossible until we
transcend the limitations of our current
worldview called ineffective Theory we
need to be getting more people into the
hard Sciences we need more philanthropy
we need to get governments on board we
particularly need to get neurodivergent
people outside of the schooling system
more of them advancing radically quickly
made feel confident that they will have
lives with second homes that they can
have three children they can get help in
the house if what they're doing is
taking their rare gifts and putting them
in the service of humanity and allowing
them to participate in the prosperity
that they have built for everyone else
what a beautiful answer Eric Weinstein
thank you for coming on head on over to
locals where we continue the
conversation
what is the right balance between being
cautious in terms of not getting into a
nuclear exchange and not giving into
nuclear blackmail yeah it's a it's a
good question
[Music]